your own is such a privilege that we
women have never gotten in all of
society and you know why and how we
thank them is we [ __ ] on the men that
did it for us and the only reason why
you can be a single woman who is
actually safe is because of men
please because yeah because police
officers you know firemen you know all
the people that were going to protect
you are going to be men I need to say
something go for it bro
if I call the cops and they send me a
woman
especially here especially here because
you guys don't have guns here right what
you gonna do I'm probably taller than
her you know what if it's like a Helga
woman when I see security
average guy okay look at we play
basketball okay and you know damn well
that an average guy that's not muscular
that's like skinny can still beat us and
we're in shape yeah
and I'm like wait what on Earth is a
woman gonna do to help me so so that
being said though pal so you're pretty
red poo and you're pretty based anyway
but what is it that makes women who
actually know this because you just said
when I say a woman security guard I'm
like right what is it that makes women
try to to go against the the nature that
we already know that when men say men
are masculine we're stronger we don't
know this what is a pushback why do
women always push back against that
I can't talk for women I just feel like
I just feel like
is being pushed a lot saying that oh we
need to stop being masculine but it's
just based on just Independence like
let's say worst case scenario single
moms they do everything by themselves I
mean but I do understand where you guys
are coming from like there are roles
based for men period like plumbers I
actually get that but it's like I feel
like in society today women can do that
too but it's not maybe to the extent of
a man can do it as efficient as sharp as
more practical I mean we're definitely
gonna maybe ask for help a little extra
help from somebody doesn't actually
necessarily I think yeah I think the
point is that if all if all men
disappeared tomorrow women would be
screwed Wherever not screwed
hahaha
depending on what you identify as a
woman oh wow exactly
I think I can answer your question and
why women
do that I think it's because what men do
we can put value on it a monetary value
on it and women's natural skills is hard
to monetize it in terms of so if you're
a woman and you're caring and you're
feminine and you're affectionate it's
hard to put a price price on that and
you can't sell something that you can't
really put a price on and I feel like
because we understand the value of money
and obviously if we can say oh a man can
do this and this is worth this amount we
evaluate more as opposed to a woman who
can take care of a home and take care of
the children we're like well how much is
that actually worth
do you go and say so people are
naturally going to assume because you
can put a price on whatever men do it
might be more valuable as opposed to
what a woman can do which is equally as
valuable and different but we just don't
know how to put a price on it because if
you say for example um teachers or
Nursery nurse they don't necessarily get
paid a lot even though the job is
extremely valuable do you understand but
didn't there used to be a time where men
saw women as Priceless anyway and what
they've done is priceless
I think it's because women are less
valuable nowadays
because we're we're not pure are there
like women aren't virgins anymore and
we're older than ever when we get
married the average age of first
marriage in the UK is 31. how many
bodies does a girl got by 31.
and so like like they might have
worshiped the ground the women from the
1950s walked on but those women had
cookbooks they were mothers they were
wives like half of our generation wasn't
even raised by wives how the hell would
they know how to be one exactly so
that's what I said like back in the days
you would think of a woman as Priceless
yeah you can't actually put a price on
what they do because it in theory it's
Priceless as opposed to a man there is a
price for your your skill set your value
and all of this kind of thing however I
think it's like what do you call it um
marketing that's got people confused to
think like because you could put a price
on something that it's valuable and what
most things you that aren't um that are
Priceless are the most things that hold
value to you do you understand if that
makes sense so going back to the video
Candace Owen said um that no Society can
kind of survive
without strong men absolutely not
um however this Society seems to be
telling men that they can be women
right and
um literally literally women and so if
we live in a society now that as
everybody knows because what she said to
me isn't that controversial because we
know that Society should survive with
strong men so if our society Western
Society is now telling men there can be
women what do you think the future for
the society is going to be Jesus has
that every civilization that was like
female-led crashed
yeah
sorry gone I was thinking about
something like this of recently and the
reason why I was thinking about it is
because I saw a school student walking
around with a bonnet on his head
and I've seen this quite frequently like
young kids wearing bonnets young male
boys men yeah men wearing bonnets on
their head just casually and I thought
this is so interesting I feel like
what's gonna happen maybe not for Our
Generation but the next generation of
young people kids or whatever
I think the women are actually going to
be attracted to feminine men I said well
okay well you say you said this and
you've got the um of course you've got
the K-pop phenomenon haven't you yeah
the androgynous type of man yeah yeah
exactly so that is that's that's
definitely possible but is that really
what they're viscerally going to desire
I mean maybe it is yeah I think it's
already happening I have no I have I
don't I don't know if it was you that
told me this but someone I was on an
Instagram live a couple months ago and
they were talking about
would you date a guy that had like done
stuff with like another guy in the past
yeah and I was like no like nesky not a
never and or like a like bot like they
were a guy that was bi and they said the
younger generation doesn't care and he's
like call your sister and I was like no
way she'll say yes like no way so I call
her and I'm like like Eva Amelia my two
younger sisters like would you date a
guy that's bi and they're both like Yeah
well yeah you know I was I mean they're
young like um my one sister is 19. oh
and my other sister us
because to me it was like a quick ew no
and my my other sister that's 21 22. I
have nine siblings I forget but but she
said no but there seemed to be a cut off
with like the youngest too because
that's the thing like like you were just
saying I've said it on the show uh a
couple of times that women are now being
attracted to feminine men because
they're becoming more masculine the more
feminine the guy because you know
essentially Opposites Attract and like
you were saying um about the the cave
pop phenomenon yeah where men are
looking less like men and more like
Harry Styles Harry Styles yeah right
um men are starting to look less like
men and more kind of morphing into like
man womanly type yeah I don't know
androgynous type men and so that's what
women are becoming attracted to
a lot of women at all but a lot of women
are becoming attractive yeah but don't
you don't you think in some ways though
the sort of the raw masculine archetype
still wins through because if you look
if you if you read a lot of the sort of
like the the online advice that's
directed at man it's all very much I
mean what is everyone bang on about the
whole time it's all it's all lifting
lift you know lift lift 15 times a day
and stuff
um and and it's all geared towards
becoming that ape that sort of so-called
Apex Alpha type guy and I think
ultimately that that still cuts through
because if you take it to a slightly
lesser extreme not necessarily about
people who are androgynous because
that's that's one thing but what about
the sort of man boobed sort of
chest feeling Millennium sort of dude
who's got the sort of hipster beard and
oh and carries a tote bag you know that
kind of guy right he's sort of like he's
not feminine as such but he's also not
sort of archetypally mass you know the
edges have been softened haven't they
right yeah yeah Society so I think then
if you're like an Andrew Tate type
character you know you kind of cut
through all that all that BS and you
sort of still make it however I feel
like this is a this is one of the first
times in history that the weak have
governed the strong well yeah yeah like
the tech overlords right so like so
these guys generally are like as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible